This is Miss Sydeon.
Sydeon.
[MUSIC]
Hello, nice to meet you guys.
Hi, hi.
Hello to Marvel.
[LAUGHING] We were just
talking about the fact
that this is your very
first film premiere.
What's it like to be here?
Oh my gosh, it's amazing.
I never thought that playing
video games was going to get me
on the purple carpet here
interviewing with you guys
and hanging out with Marvel,
but what a journey it's been.
I'm glad to be here.
So let me ask you this.
Because even though
it's your first carpet,
you did not come to play.
Thank you.
Tell us about this outfit,
because you look amazing.
Head to toe, I love everything.
Thank you.
Well, I'm dressed today.
I got everything from StockX.
So I have my Chanel earrings,
I have my off white dress,
I have my Amina Muaddi shoes.
And then I have my
Brandon Blackwood
end systemic racism bag here.
This purple little
number, I love it.
Can we get like a little
highlight on that bag really
quickly?
The color matches so well.
It's beautiful.
I love the way.
It matches my dress.
I am like super, super
happy with the way
I'm dressed tonight.
Well, we know you're a
great StockX ambassador.
Obviously, head to toe.
Can you tell us a little bit
about your love of Marvel,
the Marvel fandom, how that's
always integrated for you
into video games as well?
Yeah, absolutely.
So I was just
explaining earlier,
like I grew up with
bedtime stories,
but it was comic books.
So my dad is like the
biggest Marvel fan,
and that was what I was
learning about when I was a kid
and what I was reading.
So it just transcended
into this like thing.
I started gaming,
reading comics more,
talking about comics
on stream, and now
I'm at a Marvel premiere.
It happens like that.
Yeah, wow.
And you know what does it mean
for you to be at this Marvel
premiere in particular?
What does that mean to you?
Oh gosh, it means everything.
Like I think that feeling like
I'm a piece of representation
in gaming for like younger
Black women, younger
just Black kids
in general, to be
able to be here and
see representation
on the big screen and be
able to celebrate that is
the absolute best feeling.
For my first
premiere, I wouldn't
have wanted it any other way.
Absolutely.
I love that.
So exciting.
Well, as our final question,
we have to ask, is there anyone
you're insanely
excited to see tonight?
Anything you're insanely
I have to go with just
the movie in general.
Like I'm so, so excited.
Like every time I've watched
the trailer for Black Panther,
I've gotten chills.
Like just absolute tears.
I know it's going to be a moving
one, and I'm very excited.
Absolutely.
Get in there then.
We'll see you inside.
- It's great to meet you, Syd.
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you.
Lovely to-- meet you.